[Musique]
david inhalent bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat pour les élections municipales
et communautaires aux anses d'arlet
alors ce n'est pas votre première
candidature on en a déjà parlé
je crois même qu'il s'agit là de la
quatrième pour l'élection dé mars 2020
qu'est ce qui vous pousse encore à
vouloir être merde et en harley nous
sommes dans une progression constante et
400 voire 700 voix 900 voix donc ça
monte et par ailleurs c'est dans
l'alliance arlésienne nous avons toute
une équipe de militants de 6,3 rien de
personnes qui travaillent donc il faut
continuer le combat
donc voilà et donc nous avons à travers
la dernière mandature pu bénéficier
puisque nos étudiants élus cette fois
puisque les mandats lisant ça les a
dépassés domicile à abidjan
vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition oui sortant ouais nous
sommes quatre vous êtes 4 et vous même
la tête de liste de l'alliance aérienne
david finale vous avez été présent tout
au long de toutes les voitures conseil
municipal au sein des commissions et
pour mener les débats de fond autant sur
le compte administratif les comptes
administratifs les aspects d'aménagement
est tous vraiment ça a été déterminant
pour nous dans cette mandature nous les
élus mais aussi les militants puisque
nous travaillons avec tout le monde
autour des projets d en parler alors
avant d'en venir à ce que vous proposez
quel serait votre priorité si si si vous
êtes élu et puis selon voulant l'enjeu
majeur qui se joue pour les allées les
arlésiennes et et les arlésiens juste
rappeler que pour les législatives de
2010 est vous étiez candidat pour dans
la circonscription du sud
d'ailleurs vous dites souvent que vous
avez gagné faux sens d'arles et louie
vega dit aux anses d'arlet j'ai gagné
aux trois ilets et d'un beau coup de com
et dans la majorité des communes j'étais
second de dans les élections donc
c'était de retrait un très bon parcours
donc du coup vous avez l'investiture du
ppm et 2 pmn non cet avis aussi pâles
comme nous sommes au conseil municipal
dans une alliance qui est assez large et
diversifiée jouer le soutien du parti
mais de manière générale du bbm et donc
de manière générale c'est l'alliance
arlésienne qui mène le combat d'accord
alors donc si vous êtes élu
effectivement à la tête de la mairie d
installer david dinel quel sera votre
dossier prioritaire alors le disque d'un
dossier prioritaire c'est le revitaliser
le beau puisque aujourd'hui nous avons
un gros 1 go dossier qui est celui du
parking de l'entrée du bo qui veut être
vendus qui doit qui devrait être vendu à
des as des as des promoteurs alors que
c'est déterminant pour le développement
de la ville en matière de restauration
en matière de tourisme et même de
spectacles et de la vie de la commune
vous disant dus à des promoteurs mais
pour faire un projet peut-être
structurants n'ont même pas de nous
lasser il faut ya des éléments qui sont
fondamentaux un parking vient pas tant
en terme d'aménagement et de
développement
or nous avons à côté 400 m² de
l'ancienne école du bo justement nous
aurions préféré que les deux soient
organisés autrement
d'ailleurs il y a aujourd'hui une
enquête publique qui se fait sur ça donc
je demande aux arlésiens
je propose aux arlésiens d'aller en mai
oui justement peau donner leur avis sur
cette enquête publique concernant le
parking donc développer la ville et
aménager le fond de mer deuxième élément
fondamental c'est au niveau de
l'ensemble de la commune et des
quartiers c'est accéder à l'habitat
aujourd'hui les gens parler beaucoup de
monde mais le pied dès les pieds damon
on a toujours habité près de la mer il
nous faut conquérir le pied damon et il
faut donc aménagé et permettre que le
plan local d'urbanisme
surtout que nous sommes propriétaires ce
sont nos aïeux qui ont défriché contre
les serpents et est donc jeudi à tokyo
tout faux quichaud profiter de varela
pour faire de la spéculation immobilière
non c'est non mais j'ai décidé de 61 ans
division on pourra pas faire de
spéculation immobilière on va se
partager chacun petits morceaux
selon la tradition et puis on va
développer mais le politique est là pour
l'aménagement général aller chercher
tout ce qui est possible en terme de
fonds pour l'aménagement
faut-il le rappeler vous êtes un ancien
sportif de compétition oui oui je fais
des volets du marathon semi-marathon
au delà donc de ce point de vue sport
oui alors car jusque là dessus juste un
loisir justement au niveau des jeunes
aujourd'hui ils ont inondé les trois
associations racing club arlésien
aujourd'hui football club et le rayon
ils ont des subventions demi heure nous
avons fixé des bars à dix mille dix
mille euros pour les petites et puis les
20000 euros
donc on va faire des arbitrages
budgétaires et puis à côté de ça il
faudra accompagner les jeunes dans tout
ce qu'ils ont aidé à faire une formation
et sur le rôle du politique et des
politiques et des administratifs
justement je profite pour saluer tous
les administratifs puisque nous venons
pour les accompagner pour les former et
leur permettre d'aller plus loin dans
leur cursus professionnel david finale
pour conclure qu est ce qui se joue de
très important pour les en harley et sa
population
là dans deux mois pour ce scrutin
sachant que le maire sortant alors on ne
sait pas encore s'il va se représenter
ou pas mais le maire sortant était aussi
président de la communauté
d'agglomération cap sud espace sud
excusez moi et donc bon c'est quand même
oui mais non non mais laisse en parler
dans ce cas ci ce n'est qu'une
collectivité qui a ramassé les
compétences des communes
c'est la loi nôtre mais aujourd'hui
l'espace sud
c'est pas lui qui s'est pas d'espacé que
nous apporte le maximum c'est l'état
c'est le roi s'est tout d'un coup c'est
tous ces projets il faut aller chercher
des fonds l'espace sud n'est qu'un
complément ne faut pas croire que
l'esprit sud est capable de développer
une commune
sinon toutes les communes de shit
j'aurais déjà développé merci david
finale
[Musique]